ufc is expanding its octagon plans in
the works to stretch the combat sports
complex that exists down in the
southwest valley clark county
commissioners recently approved the
request which includes hosting larger
crowds hector mejia reporting live this
morning in the southwest valley and
hector this is good news for ufc fans
it definitely is and when this
multi-million dollar production house
opened just recently back in 2019 ufc
said it was part of an even larger
master plan and here we are learning
about more plans they're working to make
this building even bigger and be able to
host up to a thousand people during
special events by adding 17 000 square
feet of space to this now map gives us a
bird's bird's-eye view of the potential
construction zone the apex facility here
right next door to the fight promotions
headquarters by south jones and the 215.
well the plans call for the expansion of
the existing building plus adding more
parking space here on a portion of 31
acres clark county commissioners
recently gave the plan of the green
light just last week and it could also
potentially bring shops snack bars
lounges and restaurants to the site a
ufc spokesperson told me they're just
looking to add seating and improve the
overall fan experience and immediately
after the pandemic shutdowns the ufc was
the first to bring live sports back to
las vegas but we've also learned
construction crews are anticipating
running into supply chain issues which
is the reason why they told county
commissioners they're breaking up the
project in different phases and again
they're working to add 17 000 square
feet of space to this existing building
here right behind us reporting live
hector mejia live local now